so ready to see once again what Nikolas
Nikolas did this cage are you ready to
sheet what Nicholas Cage will do for a
paycheck how the bloody shit is that
possible can you tell an American rap my
lines I also have an amazing instrument
it's my penis please do I was aggressive
please do
haha how elegant and charming nah I'll
read were you ever a goth girls like
face okay she does dye her hair oh yeah
that's right about the clothes yeah okay
so you do slip very naturally into it
right it's like I'll sort of say like
you know us like yeah we'll get away
guys like we don't need a way you guys
yeah yeah sure we don't need to yeah
okay all right
yeah rape it at the dog ready action
I'm sorry I swear that never happens you
know just every once awhile I say I know
I screwed up the line we can't do it
again I'm just gonna do it life do a lot
all right ready all right I swear that
never happens you know I usually stay in
human form but if everyone - well you
just touched me a certain way - cuts off
and all that happens a lot of lies the
phone over there you want call
nine-one-one or whatever I'm just going
to start scraping at the door
when will you get the case oh he just
got drunk oh I didn't even know there
was a ghostwriter sequel it's I mean
it's both a little better and a little
worse than the last place at the Sun but
we get a cage freak out at least I mean
that's the thing at least we get in you
know like going over the topic you know
all myself so that's great okie dokie
yeah I used to be able to get my eyes
bigger when I looked out like really
have them like big as I look down that's
it's getting harder oh yeah no it is I
tried to train my face to do it because
that's always something I know it's like
comedians are really good at that like I
could look any direction keep their eyes
wide open right but looking at it's
really difficult cuz your eye you know
yes I would you need to do that
naturally calves like we look down so
yeah alright oh good okay so we got that
no you have stay up Dylan oh yeah oh
yeah so go ahead stay is that you want
to talk about KJ talking that way that's
cool oh all right I'm good that was
awful
all night you did Wow we're gonna die
she's in this visit dad yes there's no
light for life there's only cough oh
okay so I'm going to shoot the devil
boner scene and yeah because I have to
do that now because I'm gonna put on all
the black makeup and the villain in this
looks a lot like double boner just
really and there's white makeup yeah
we're just gonna add on top of that so
uh you got it so go ahead relax Thanks
write poetry about death time to be the
devil's boner say you ever see a Hotel
Transylvania no hey that's really good
is that the surprisingly really really
good is that the animated movie yeah
with Adam Sandler yeah don't actually
good yeah I know I've heard I've heard
good things about it's actually really
good for a Halloween movie too so but
she looks like the girl in there like
very much like I forget the name but
yeah it's all man all right I'll check
it out yeah and you people at home check
it out check it out wife beater Nicolas
Cage what glasses that that cage with
the glasses that is so cool this should
be like a character for your Halloween
getup all black music dressing Goethals
like I'll wear black yeah that's pretty
much it yeah oh so like I see face oh uh
huh oh I got the DVD for you yes you're
welcome
yeah it's gonna have to put in your
possession so I'm about to do devil
boner in a second I couldn't remember
you had a black shirt or white shirt I'm
like well character was really popular
so I'm like okay I'll just type it in
images that you know I say I'm sure
they'll pop up first I'm like I pray
that pop up first
that ain't what Papa magic that's what
popped up first what is that I don't
know anyway it looks like a boner
like a gummy devil yeah I don't know
like like the others army you know but
yeah I just saw that whoa
so yeah almost number one yeah I don't
think atop that it is that what you were
dressed oh come on the devil uh there's
this um if there's gonna be a seeing
this review pricing already where
Malcolm is dressed up like a character
called cut storm and we actually did
that for the first Ghost Rider with you
but what we found out that we watched
the director's cut of Ghost Rider and
there's a few extra scenes and they're
all edited like how the second ones
edited where is like oh really faster
than really slow and then really fast
backwards and then regular again and I
just hate that kind of editing you know
it's kind of baz lurman editing where
it's just like you know yeah you can
press fast-forward Wow uh so we shot it
but then we realized that when I was
editing the movie I didn't have the
director's cut so I just had this scene
I'm like well crap what the hell do I do
with this so I marry Tony I'm like yeah
they're just the end of a movie where
they use that style will just use it
then and sure enough the movie the head
it was ghosts right their new sequel
yeah so who would have thought so yeah
so if you don't see it behind the scenes
of table to go to cut storm outfit
that's why cuz we had a shot it like
more than half at your oh wow yeah so is
it the same director it's the first one
no that's what you do that's hilarious
I don't think it I could be wrong IMDB
you leave angry comments if I'm wrong
and um yeah this is just so if you see
no cast or that's why in this
behind-the-scenes yeah no cut storm
anyways who I'm right here Jim
well yes is all off limits get out no I
would say you have to get Doug's devil
boner getting put on well gje for
whatever reason like the characters that
only get a few seconds of screen time
becoming sanely popular right you as the
assassin Betty he did not expect that at
all everybody's like bring that guy back
I don't like what he'll do I do with
this right I sure enough there's the
scene in Ghost Writer were like he's
transforming he just like he's all he's
very he just looks like oh he's evil
cartoon characters cuz it's all done so
weird and silly yeah it just half of
them with like devil boners I'm just
like okay extending can be a ghost
writer villain yes but child friendly
yes it's being a which we have Rachel
coming back for this episode
oh yeah that's exciting yeah cos in the
movie the devil has a sideman s just say
well we have a devil with a kid too you
know might as well do something like
that yeah yeah when I saw her in the
script I was like wow I was kind of like
is she coming back in my god she has
this this is so she's a client for one
quick second cameo nobody because we
gave her the evil lean alpha and she
always said if you ever need me for a
kami or something you know I can always
film it and that's perfect yeah cuz I
know at some point I'm going to use the
devil again and I was just like well
might as well you know having like what
where's evil even gonna be so I just
have they like send her on a trip it's
like this this is the perfect movie to
do it with cuz like you know white
doesn't the devil keep track of his
studies like you're gonna be the vessel
to which I enter and say what did you
hold on to all that why are you letting
this you know relatively good-natured
woman look after these guys corrupt him
with goodness right okay it's like I
want no part of you it's like yeah
because you didn't friggin race on the
right or wrong way oh yeah I like I yeah
we're in Texas just well on see I was
trying to think of
why it's like I wanted to do something
evil you know we could get a big laugh I
was like you know and I was like I've
used Joe on anything for awhile I asked
if he could do a cameo it's like yeah
sure so I was like yeah let's just do
taxes then it's pretty awesome yeah
Ingrid you I'm sure she could find some
part california looks like taxes oh yeah
it's gotta be some part around here
there's bad weather I mean when she shot
her cameo for face off flight you see
her there she's like in this beautiful
room and has like a mimosa right okay
she it was just like the perfect
lighting - she was all glowing and yeah
great complexion because people don't
realize she's hideous real lady yeah I
know it's like the the acne the scars
the bruises and I'll know she does to
herself in the off time but I mean she's
the wonders of maketh assistant Tamra to
it people don't know that gothic that's
just her without the makeup oh wow no
everyone think she puts on makeup on us
just which it looks like I didn't know
that
yeah well this - I mean this is we're
not putting on makeup we're taking off
makeup
wow it's the magic of you know Internet
productions I mean we're all hideous
people
but yeah we get great wizards like this
guy just remove or who've all that
makeup yeah I can put it back on sorry
that's not want take a look at it see I
can't remember exactly sure and this is
you said this was the Tetsuo II I think
it's technically to Dragon Ball Z weight
which is really nice but yeah but when
we shot the holy flea and let me see how
it comes together the most black makeup
like this the goth chick and Carrie
juice
yeah does he like
little more shadows maybe I think
there's a little bit more shit yeah I
think there actually wasn't I think I
was gonna say I think with the nose um
it's not don't worry about is there a
way to get it where it doesn't go
actually above the eyebrow yeah yeah um
and I think that's what you can possibly
do is just take the ones off the eyebrow
maybe add a little more to the
cheekbones at the other word I can't
heavier like the yo top I like the
chicas line and say yeah well like not
too much but a little bit because
something I always notice I know society
has an illustrator when the if the black
lines like if they work into the
eyebrows that's fine if you go above
them or or if you don't they have them
go above like it makes the brow look
more menacing and makes it look like
it's getting a much harsher look but
yeah that's true yeah that's why I like
you never it Scissorhands but you know
so joined up but we like every shot he
looks Sam again we traveled angry he
looks sad that's because they actually
painted on the worried words on him so
no matter what he always you know has
that look out on the right and devil
Boehner has to look menacing gaze but
yeah that's a good point like the little
characters always end up becoming yes I
girls like more that more of them give
us more so we can become sick of them
because Buster's three argument that was
a line I was gonna put it with hyper
fangirl I could fit in though it's like
you know there's one join the petition
to get Ghostbusters 3 going so we could
all hate it
there's nothing you can do to make
everybody happy with Ghostbusters 3
that's your room when they were all
alive you couldn't do it right is it
even when two came out everybody was
well
it's selected hate to make another one
really ya know a lot of people didn't
like to that's not so shocked everyone's
like do do a 3 2 or 3 I'm like wait -
yeah but they're older and slower now
huh oh
just like the food see what she's
talking about
first audition in college
oh yeah oh nice and he has his first
audition today and for the first
audition they make you much the same
he's going same school that I went to
anyway John House cool and for the first
auditions they make you audition in
front of your whole class which is like
20 people the second year class which is
like 20 people the entire faculty which
is like 30 people and like you're
auditioning on the main stage and
they're just do sort of shit sure
oh wow yeah this is first audition yes
oh I think you'll be alright
it's cool Wow
Halloween the footsteps of the fame
really yeah Wow yeah Chicago's got some
theater out here it's really good for
novice it's better the eye it's better
to do that go to a city like Chicago
first before you go to like right cuz
it's like you have to have a big name
and resume you can't go to New York
school credits right thanks for coming
yeah she cackled has a really open venue
for theater just like yeah come on in
and you know ed while you're trying to
figure out your spirit lives and also
other things yeah yeah what's the
independent mmm the indie scene in
Chicago is pretty big yeah and it's
growing to Chicago's more and warmer
destinations yes the destination people
are coming to to just kind of converge
this season there's like six shows
filming in Chicago really yeah hmm my
gosh how fired yeah oh no there was
Chicago PD yeah there's like just and
there's a hole mmm I want to get on that
back Travis ooh are you represented by
uh Stuart Stuart Alan you're what Stuart
yeah you did yeah I just started the
application process to agencies this
week last week nice great I applied the
Stuart and I mentioned this autocratic
so hopefully they'll see that be like oh
we know so much yeah yeah they could
they very well could cuz like my agents
are like Malcolm you've been doing a lot
of great things I see behind the scenes
huh and like yeah you know and we just
hurt the mating call of a hot oops sorry
I was cozy cheers in your teeth I'm
snuggly and soft my mom never loved me
oh my gosh I can think I'm not laying
soft my mom never loved me my drama with
just that weird sound is done
I'm snuggly and soft I know she do that
and Oh devil bone this is what's up Oh
Oh make up for that well okay okay now
we're gonna use it cuz this makeup
blends in so well with the other bad guy
from the movie we're just gonna put
white over oh wow
so who's the other bad guy he's a guy
who's like he's just a gangster of a
typical henchman villain whatever and
then like the devil comes and gives him
the power of decay so anything he
touches decay but he also gives them the
power of like horrible fashion sense
because remember the albino bad guys
oops oh that happens they just kind of
snap together okay just like um remember
the albino bad guys from matrix - oh
yeah yeah he looks like that except not
as stylish Oh light looks really really
bad really lame you know like since our
weird punk rocker which is like if you
look like that before okay but it's like
he didn't you just looked like you know
a siren like a wife the devil have that
fashion that's true hmm it's like I'm a
rebel
it's like oh maybe I shouldn't do that
maybe other movies like don't the
dresses are due or whatever but it's
like you know I need to stay human I
need to have my human form and both my
brother like why yeah that's the point
it's like I imagine could do much more
is like you know without the
restrictions of a human body and it's
like the movie ends with a car chase
it's like the devil's in a fucking car
driving it's like the movie she said
what a skull bow or whatever it is yeah
Jim was having a hard time with that one
it's just the quality of wigs that we
have our best right there budgeted wigs
yeah I mean good razor leg
yeah very good
yeah this is like your second time
having to do or third time having to
deal with this week yeah this wicked I
go way back
lucky ward for lady love embrace uh said
also the Kirsten Dunst see this was the
wedding oh oh yeah I think I'm pretty
sure it's just let it go week oh wow
yeah yeah no that wasn't the Kirsten
Dunst week no it ended up not being the
Kirsten Dunst wig though Dana should
have played Pearson test Yeah right he
looks so much like her
yeah very striking gossip yeah
so that is a nice jacket though innit
yes putting it on and I was like you
know get makeup on this right where did
you get that like years ago where it got
a bigger than the zipper broke oh yes if
it isn't thanks you got that dust off
for evil huh it's adjusting cuz
everybody was like you devil bone or his
own show a nothing like oh yeah that
worked great
yeah there's so much opportunity
obviously like what the hell would I
even do I was like you know it's just
like you know puppies your puppies
blowing up you kids blowing on your
French in France blowing up enough
telling you know that would probably get
the more do you see friends or France oh
you know funny enough like thank you for
giving I have up here oh that I'm doing
this like yeah just do making us of it
oh yeah
beard very good Nicolas Cage grew a
beard once it strangely enough looked
fake yeah yeah totally looks fake no
it's real it's like what Jo or something
yeah looks like one of those like
knitted beards yeah yeah I even he's
authentic Lee unauthentic it's worth
yeah people makeup thing ever yeah well
the big thing everybody says I don't
know but sure I think it is but is there
one reasons he does so many movies
discussing some financial trouble we
dance
right well but some a tray of what my
brother on his honeymoon he went to Fiji
and they're doing this like boat to Rams
like you know and that Island over there
that Island used to be owned like the
coos kaj you know it's like it's like
really it's like no wonder you forget
prawns what is my only bought three best
thing is like my mom has a fat crush
under really yeah wait wait
Oh what harsh a fat brush what does that
mean geez like a big crash yeah okay
been doing for on some weight goes right
you know I mean not that I won't make
those jokes I'll totally make those
still but that would mean you know she
liked the fat but Nicolas Cage as yeah
if you do that's high that was just sort
of like that how specific I like cheese
really fabulous that's like some people
like all this they are two different
Elvis this via that's copy a rock star
thing you don't hear too many people say
you know yeah like fat Brandon yeah okay
was okay but when you got fat yeah some
people can pull it off I eat even Wells
as drunk and stay like some tea for like
he still has the crop at all yeah works
so we have lots of prep work for Doug's
rolls to this day I will admit I was
trying to make this week
kind of like easier since the last one
we were all sweating up a storm
oh I can't wear like the whole day stuff
yeah it's like yeah let's just make us a
lot easier and it's like it's Caesar
just a lot of makeup it's like it's a
shooting
yeah well luckily we didn't have to wear
a lot of makeup there Tamra had to wear
several layers yeah oh I remember I was
debating whether or not like to have you
wear like the purple shirt the whole
time as a people should you know I like
the idea of having a sore me you don't
mourn for her don't go back to the
orange afaik it is like if I knew is
gonna be hot I won't get to just the
purple yeah we were all pretty layered
up yeah you're wearing all black yeah
bring it all black suit that was a smart
suit though thank you um over the
weekend I did a parody video with some
guys I know who were on the site now how
given that's their actual day Oh some
guys yeah I'm just like some guys look
like hell
you'll be the next at 70 show like
people would just now yeah and we were
doing like a parody of musical Cats and
oh maybe I should say this whatever oh
she's like we're revering up his car
back there and her bike um we were doing
a parody of the musical Cats
and so we're bark faces were covered in
makeup and it was so hot out this
weekend
oh by the end of the shoot we had like a
choreographed dance so we did by the end
of the shoot no one it was just it's
melting off sounds awesome I think I saw
pictures of that actually it's awesome
she's very upset
oh yeah that's our hey this looks like a
character to now well just added on the
leather jacket really asked devil bone
ah yeah bhana
Davone are active it is yeah it was a
button in fuck if I promise to miss you
will you go away did you a button this
assistant on this awesome
$200 and I am
stark low Starkel home well what was
your the angelic metal singer is that
what you say oh he also beat boxes
that's his name even sounds like a metal
group it's just black out yeah I did I'm
sure there is one
oh yeah at least there was either get
the band back together man
the thing about changing the name rob
was a bunch of little bands growing up
oh wow gas masks catalog awesome right
kettle ah that's an amazing Wow
and they were like they're like kids man
they were like 15 16 Wow I like on
baggage pigs
was it a vehicle bondage fairies right a
daughter is a lady though yeah but yeah
they're not 15 yeah yeah like 40 mm I
think that all of it
I don't know where to get on the bag
I sort of idea nada
yeah mr. minions Oh another producer on
the site oh my god Malcolm is like so
cute that's a thing oh I totally did
yeah
he's taunting you shot oh oh you're sure
thing another thing up I hear he wears a
lot of dresses I don't know have you
seen his rack Oh behind the scenes
behind the scenes what the people want
it yeah I was always thinking about
doing Callie and the Brian did bright
lights it's um a long time ago was like
the internet true Hollywood story it was
sort of like that's pretty simple with
the producers like just showing like you
know make it like a drug abuse and
alcohol and you know there were former
child stars and everything I was always
think about like kind of bringing that
back or there was something similar
today so we thought that's a funny I
think he's done I just show us like you
know the chick behind you know this
sounds you're Greg and you again you
guys just like you know yeah you know
the orgies were tough did you co yeah no
one knew but Tamara is addicted to black
tar heroin wow you're such a thing yeah
you just made that up
oh man or like uh um wow what is the
name of that one reality show
oh that one yeah that what is it
no there was like a how we're all living
in a house together again there's yeah
real world have any fun you do like a
channel awesome real work yeah it's like
a
right so you get a serve I gotta like
make a production in like two hours
film something see the big thing up I
really gotta focus on getting the eye
stuff off cuz like every single time
I've done makeup like it has a lot of
black around instead of I've done the
review it always looks like am wearing
eyeliner oh oh like it I was like what
are you wearing eyeliner second once it
was black makeup okay it's kind of
eyeliner but you know what I mean and
then we will always it twice the creek
so against guys wearing eyeliner this is
a system clearly anyone that's not a
hundred percent masculine as male 100%
feminist female dye said the very
feminine male felt it sports quien the
brain brain brain brain brain good night
princess
now I'm uncle my sweet critic the
maniacs say to the max
Wow huntin dog holy shit